قالت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه ان الخارجيه
الامريكيه استدعت سفيره اسرائيل في واشنطن
مايك هارتزوق بعد اقرار الكنيسه قانونا
يلغي اخلاء اربعه مستوطنات في شمال الضفه
الغربيه من جهه اعربت نائبه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي واندي تشيرمان اعربت للسفير
الاسرائيلي عن قلق واشنطن من هذا الاجراء
الذي وصفته بالاستفزازي واوضحت المسؤوله
الامريكيه ان من شان هذه الخطوه
الاسرائيليه ان تدفع الى مزيدا من التوتر
خلال شهر رمضان واعياد الفصح اليهودي
والمسيحي يذكر ان الكنيست الاسرائيلي
صادقه بالقراءتين الثانيه والثالثه على
الغاء بنود في قانون فك الارتباط بشان
اربع مستوطنات شماليه الضفه الغربيه بعد
18 عاما من اقراره ما يتيح للمستوطنين
دخول هذه المستوطنات مره اخرى والعوده
للاقامه فيها